so I've talked about alan dershowitz
before right attorney Alan Dershowitz he
has become a total complete immoral
unhinged defender of Donald Trump and of
trumps administration and I don't know
what happened to Alan Dershowitz I don't
really have any hypotheses but it's
really really bad and right after Trump
campaign chairman Paul Manafort former
Trump campaign chairman Paul Manafort
was sent to jail by a federal judge
early this weekend Alan Dershowitz shows
up on CNN and he said and I couldn't
believe it when I saw it I thought I
must have heard wrong
Dershowitz said it's not fair to send
Paul Manafort to jail because they would
be jailing him with poor people and
minorities I wish I was making it up but
this is actually what Alan Dershowitz
said I'm gonna play it for you we're
gonna pick this up when Wolf Blitzer is
actually asking Alan Dershowitz about
possible future pardons from Trump for
some of these people who are on the
growing list of indict ease of this
investigation
Dershowitz just doesn't like manna for
being near minorities and poor people in
jail take a listen to this as he did
that the Muller probe quote might get
cleaned up with some presidential
pardons that's a quote could that be
interpreted potentially as inappropriate
if not illegal or unethical a signal to
potential potential subjects and
witnesses know he has a perfect right as
Trump's lawyer to assert his belief that
the matter should be pardoned my own
view is that it is terribly unfair for a
metaphor to join the thousands of other
people many of them minority people many
of them poor who are sitting in jail
with a presumption of innocence we don't
know whether he tampered with the
witnesses how dare they put Paul
Manafort in the same place as not just a
few but potentially thousands of
minorities and poor people as insane as
it sounds at face value even it's sort
of like thinking about what point he
might be trying to make I genuinely have
no idea what the hell Alan Dershowitz
met by the
and I I wonder like as it as simple as
man afford is better than minorities and
poor people so he shouldn't be jailed
with them and then he goes on to try to
clean it up apparently something
alight what go went off and Alan
Dershowitz his mind where he said wait a
second maybe that didn't sound good so
he tries to clean it up by saying this
is a broader comment about pretrial
detention of all people whether it's
rich or poor let's check out that clip
and see if it makes it any better all we
know is he's been indicted for that you
can indict you can get a grand jury to
indict a ham sandwich this so undercuts
the presumption of innocence when we put
people in jail or or rich but without a
trial without a hearing based on a
judge's conclusion and a prosecutor's
assertion that they may have violated
the bail I agree okay so here it
actually gets a little more interesting
right because here Alan Dershowitz is
making a comment about pretrial
detention in general and I actually do
understand those concerns but the
problem of pretrial detention isn't one
of disproportionately white rich men
being unfairly held in part but
partially because they have better
lawyers it's the poor and the minorities
that are disproportionately suffering as
a result of pretrial detention and the
rich white dudes with the good lawyers
that are not suffering because of unfair
pretrial detention it's not Paul
Manafort so if Dershowitz is saying that
he believes pretrial detention is a
problem in general I'm actually right
there with him this is connected to the
bail bonds industry which I've spoken
about before I would love to hear Alan
Dershowitz get out there and say
pretrial detention is unfairly
disproportionately hurting poor people
and minorities but to bring up the
unfairness of pretrial detention because
it's Paul Manafort who's being held
pretrial after clearly violating the
terms of his bail by contacting
witnesses that and trying to influence
their testimony the problem of pretrial
detention is not epitomized by Paul man
affords presence in a jail right now the
poor and minorities who are being held
pretrial for minor crimes because they
can't afford bail are the problem man
fort had bail revoked because he started
contacting witnesses and as a side note
mana fort isn't really going to have to
worry about poor black and brown people
bugging him in jail because he's being
held in a VIP section anyway he's
currently the only person listed as
being in the VIP section on the prisons
website and he's probably still in
lockdown twenty or more hours a day
minimal contact with other inmates but
has his own sink and shower but
regardless the upside of the upshot for
him and for Dershowitz is that very very
few minorities and poor people are going
to be able to talk to the guy
so that should I guess make alan
dershowitz very happy if you think I'm
missing what Alan Dershowitz meant by
saying it's unfair to put him near all
these people many of them poor and
minorities please let me know on Twitter
at des Pakman or on Instagram at David
Pakman because I would love to hear from
you you can also follow the show on
twitter at david pakman show today's
episode of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by filter easy which is
a super convenient subscription service
that makes it impossible to forget to
change your air filters because filters
will arrive at your front door when you
need to change them I went I think it
was like seven or eight months when I
first moved into my place without
changing my HVAC filter needless to say
when I finally did it was bad really bad
and I don't recommend doing that the EPA
ranks poor indoor air quality is one of
the top five environmental health risks
risks and it's really important to
replace your indoor air filter on the
right schedule but a lot of people
forget very often and they also might
not know that filter easy makes it super
simple you can sign up for filter easy
in under five minutes on your computer
or phone you can actually get a
subscription service for something you
need compared to lots of other
subscription boxes it's practical it's a
no-brainer and that is why I am now
subscribing to filter easy and for
listeners and viewers of the David
Pakman show you can get your first order
for free by going to filter easy calm or
calling eight five five nine one zero
easy that's eight fifty five nine
zero three two seven nine make
absolutely sure that you use offer code
Pakman that's PA que ma n sign up at
filter easy calm get your first order
for free filter easy calm or eight five
five nine one zero easy and use the
offer code Pakman